yeah this is my work number so thank you
very much for your time thank you thank
you
right just moving on to the next and
nineteen licensing team service plan
just moving on to try and get us back to
a relative level of normality but with
some policy and operational changes that
are needed over the next six months and
great are you taking this I was gonna I
was gonna just go through the proposal
yes thank you and thank you chair and
summarize this is a report that details
the proposed operational policy changes
which needed to continue the delivery of
the taxi licensing aspects the licensing
service during the corona virus pandemic
the first follows the first day that
manages the action plan it's probably
the month of April May and June and
which was approved on the 9th of April
20-21 during under emergency powers a
copy of the emergency action plan is
attached to this report at appendix a
and you'll see that contained nine
proposals for bring how we would deal
with taxi driver and vehicle license
renewals new driver and vehicle
application medical and DBS checks mLT's
and the payment of fees during April May
and June of this year which agreed that
drivers and Bickel owners whose licenses
were to expire during that page could
apply to have their life as extended
provided there to direct the DBS
checking process required for and who
had completed a medical self
certification form the requirements to
provide any multi certificate was also
deferred in line with the government
guidance who's felt that this approach
is the most appropriate as it allowed
the licensing team to get used to new
ways of working as all staff are now
working from home but just as
importantly it supported the taxi trade
at a real difficult time and the
emergency procedures covered the period
up to the end of June so we now need a
decision and our approach in the next
phase starting on the 1st of July for
seven proposals in the report which
we're seeking approval brief they are
you want me to go through them chair are
there in front of you yet Matt and that
we begin processing driver and vehicle
license renewal from the first of July
rather than simply extending them and
where possible these continue to be
processed online that we continue to
require drivers to apply for a DBS check
online until the 31st of December when
we'll review that situation that we
require drivers in the first instance to
provide a medical certificate I'm either
own doctor where they can but if that's
not possible to allow drivers to
complete a medical self certification
form online this would be valid until
the end of the year but the suspension
of the new driver application process
continues until the 30th of September
when just before that that we all can
review that situation and decide what to
do after that date the requirement to
produce a medical and multi certificate
story is deferred until the 30th of
September when again we would review the
situation is proposed licensing officers
will attend the town hall and a limited
basis like mail and issue hardcopy
badges and plates while always observing
the social distancing rules but there's
no intention at this day to open the
licensing reception desk to deal with
customers face to face so and I'd like
to recommend the report for approval and
have to answer any questions and this
may have and on the proposals Thanks
cheer yes yeah guys it's one on the the
second proposal about certification
medicals that the driver may complete
the online sell medical self
certification until 31st December I mean
how are you going to avoid any kind of a
serious situation in that that could be
less ignored in somewhere I mean is
there any kind of protection there it's
difficult one and normally as I say we
would ask the driver to have medical
done by their own doctors that you have
access to their medical records and many
doctors are not doing those kinds of
medicals at the moment and we are
finding that many drivers are saying
they're unable to get medical clearance
and what we're asking for is them to
make a statement and obviously if it was
found that they had lied on that self
certification form then and there would
be very serious repercussions but at the
moment there's not anything you know I
fit there's no third party option for us
at the moment okay the concern is that I
mean if somebody was seriously injured
or killed you know the number of the
public being carried what would the
implications be on the council or the we
have it we have a statement made from
the drive to say that they are they
don't have any medical conditions which
should have would affect their ability
to drive and so I think an almost legal
you know could come in and say that
there's anything different that
obviously we would take that into
consideration I'm sure in court would as
well but within the absence of any other
means of checking somebody's medical
condition and we thought that this was
their the most and you know the only
option available to us to allow drivers
to continue to drive joana similar to
some other authorities doing is there
anything different that we're doing yeah
yes that's the case so that many other
greater magister authorities are
expecting classifications at the moment
in knowing shots and in short term
any other questions from anybody um so
we can approve those recommendations and
then obviously I think we'll want to get
back to doing the knowledge test as soon
as that's applicable to there hopefully
there'll be a report maybe to September
or October meeting Joanne and we can
update and see if we can move forward
from there depending on what state of
place
yes yeah thank you very much thank you
so item 5 but if there's any urgent
business and then item 6 the exclusion
resolution picture so the meeting will
stop recording at this point and will go
into private session